it turns out that keanu reeves has got
his eye on one particular superhero role
is it ghost rider silva surfer squirrel
girl you'll just have to keep watching
to find out after seeing him dodge
bullets in one iconic franchise and send
them flying into henchman's skulls in
another keanu reeves fans have had high
hopes he'll take the leap into the
superhero genre it wouldn't be his first
time of course back in 2005 reeves
brought the dc hero john constantine to
life in constantine it wasn't the most
successful comic book movie ever but
reeves has since expressed an interest
in reprising the role while that may
never come to pass it hasn't stopped him
from becoming a highly sought after star
for other projects in 2021 it was
confirmed that reeves had met marvel
head kevin feige about finding a
potential spot for him in the mcu but
there's been no word on any development
since then however it seems there's one
other avenue reeves is willing to walk
down as it's been revealed he has his
eye on one particular dc role in fact
it's a character that reeves himself has
recently tackled in the recording booth
in the newly released animated feature
dc's league of super pets keanu reeves
voices a somewhat more comedic iteration
of batman although he might not be a
central character in the movie reeves
has admitted that he has high hopes of
donning the legendary cape and kyle in
live action it's been a dream but you
know there's uh
pattinson's got batman right now and
he's doing awesome
robert pattinson hasn't crushed his
spirit entirely though with the bat fan
hopeful he might get a call eventually
maybe down the road maybe when they need
an older batman well there are a few
scenarios in which reeves could play the
role throughout dc history a number of
non-bruce wayne batman have dared to
descend on gotham's underworld what
gives you the right what's the
difference between you and me
i'm not wearing hockey pads
for example keanu reeves could find a
place in the live action dc universe not
as the billionaire playboy but as his
father thomas wayne who became a far
more vengeful vigilante in a different
timeline in the flashpoint story arc the
scarlet speedster found himself in
another timeline that saw bruce wayne
being killed in crime alley instead of
his parents this led to his father
thomas donning a cape and kyle as a more
brutal pistol packing protector of
gotham city to make matters worse the
tragedy led his wife martha to become
this timeline's joker turning the
history of two famous foes on its head
failing that of course there's one other
bruce wayne that reeves could bring to
life the incarnation seen in batman
beyond while the actor may have been
joking when he suggested playing an
older version of the character that's
actually an idea warner brothers has
entertained before in 2000 the studio
considered adapting the beloved animated
series batman beyond the show saw and
aged bruce wayne pass the kyle to a new
protege terry mcginnis from there the
new battle on the block protected the
cyberpunk influence landscape of
neo-gotham as a capeless crusader with
wayne keeping a watchful eye over him
back in the early 2000s clint eastwood
was touted as the prime choice to take
on the role of the og bat these days
michael keaton feels like an obvious
choice for the gig arguably though if a
live-action batman beyond project ever
started up again reeves action movie
experience might make him a smarter
choice whether reeves plays an elderly
bruce wayne a grizzled thomas wayne or
something else entirely there are
clearly many ways in which he could take
on the role of batman sometime in the
near future and hey if nothing else we
already know how good he looks in black
[Music]